les animaux sont les stars du salon de
l'agriculture aujourd'hui ils sont près
de 4000 mhz et à ses débuts en 1964 1500
animaux se répartissaient sur les 2600
mètres carrés du salon dès cette époque
une équipe de vétérinaires supervise les
soins au grand soulagement de cet
éleveur éléments de la bri froid pour
moi elle me dit gary de passer chez
palier d'environ parce qu'il est gay
radio les vétérinaires présents 24
heures sur 24 prodiguent des soins
gratuits et supervise l'ensemble de la
logistique quotidienne comme
l'expliquait alors ce fait terrines et
en chef
tout ce petit monde ont évidemment un
certain nombre de problèmes il faut les
nourrir il faut les traire pour les
vaches laitières
il faut apurer l'enlèvement des fumiers
dès les années 70 les vétérinaires
prennent conscience du lien qui existe
entre les conditions de vie au salon et
l'état de santé du cheptel les animaux
et l'ambiance surchauffée trouve très
mal dès les années 80 les causes du mal
être animal et les facteurs stressants
sont clairement identifiés foule
agitation et chaleur mais pas ceux nous
transporte une action changement de
régime
l'animal souffre
c'est une épreuve pour lui au début des
années 90 toujours le même constat et
même vigilance des vétérinaires qui font
le maximum pour apaiser les animaux de
cuivre appuyer les faits de manille donc
c'est dû à des conditions de l'ambiance
ils sont prêts extraordinaires font
mieux dans leurs pâtures éloignés de
leurs pâturages certes mais très
apprécié des visiteurs
si bien que le nombre d animaux n'a
cessé de progresser pour atteindre près
de 4000 tête dès les années 90 des
vétérinaires des régions viennent
renforcer les équipes
un atout d'après ce médecin limousin
dernière parisien ce qui est
essentiellement des chiens et les chats
parce qu'il ya plus de vaches sur paris
en 1995
la question du transport du bétail et au
centre des débats pour arriver au salon
certaines bêtes voyage jusqu'à 8 heures
le jour de l'inauguration 200 défenseurs
des animaux manifestent aux côtés de
brigitte bardot pour interpeller jean
puech le ministre de l'agriculture
mais du côté des vétérinaires du salon
on est affirmatif alors à fil des années
très bien transporter et à des
conditions qui va respecter elles sont
respectées par la justice
aussi bien de la part des éleveurs des
transporteurs dans les années 2000 les
vétérinaires faute de réellement pouvoir
améliorer les conditions matérielles
sont très attentif à l'équilibré
psychologique de l'animal et les animaux
de salon il y en a vraiment gagné
nommément le stress 1 il suffit qu'un a
qui commence vraiment d'aller mal les
autres vont prendre la suite certains
membres accrédités à face manière en
2018 avec une vingtaine d'interventions
par jour les douze vétérinaires associé
au salon de l'agriculture était toujours
les garants du bien-être des 4050
animaux présentés et de la réussite de
la plus grande ferme de france allait au
rock c'est bon voilà
[Musique]